hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy want to welcome you to our daily
live stream this is just a way for us to
stay in touch and have interesting
conversations we started it during times
of school closures because obviously
we're all social distanced and it's that
much more important to stay in touch but
we think it'll be fun even potentially
beyond if we hopefully who can't get
through this period sooner than later
I do remind everyone that we are
not-for-profit and the only way we're
able to do all of what we do and
especially all the things that we're
trying to do around kovat 19 support is
through philanthropic donations from
folks like yourself I do want to give a
special shout out to several of
corporations who've stepped up
especially since the crisis Bank for
America google.org AT&T fastly and
Novartis for stepping up and the many
other supporters before that we can't do
this work many of y'all might wonder how
is this free it's because of those
philanthropic donations and kind of
kinda means much more than myself it's
over 200 full-time folks working around
the world and obviously we need
resources in order to do this work so
I'm super excited about today's guest
I have Kelly testy from the law school
admissions counseling us and Kelly good
to see you it's great to see you and so
great to be with you we love the Khan
Academy we love the law school
admissions council so so we'll talk a
little bit about our relationship that
I'll remind everyone to go on to whether
you're watching this on youtube or
facebook and go on the message boards
ask any questions you'd like of Kelly
and myself and Kelly is expert on all
things law and law school so I'm
thinking we could actually be giving
legal advice but careers careers in love
me maybe we will I don't know ask us
anything ask us anything but but Kelly
may be a good place to start is what is
the law school admissions councils well
we love to basically help students find
their way to law school we think of
ourselves as an organization that helps
advance equity in law and we help
candidates find a good match
when they're looking for a law school
and make sure that we provide the
support they need to continue their
enrollment journey you know so a lot of
people don't have lawyers and their
family you know I'm a first-generation
college grad and Law School grad and so
we really try and reach out and provide
a lot of information and build the
pipeline for justice and most famously
you know the the law school admissions
test which actually I took I was pre-law
for a period of time we will go there
but I'm curious kale you know one of the
things that I like to do in these in
these live streams is just understand
how our guests ended up in the path they
they are in and you mentioned your first
generation college graduate what what
got you into the law profession what was
kind of your career arc from maybe
thinking about going a lot and now being
the head of the law school admissions
council sure well it's a it's a little
convoluted because I started my life out
wanting to be a quarterback on an NFL
team but my dad told me I was a little
short for that so I I should you know
think of something else but in all
seriousness I was very avid into sports
when I was in high school and in college
and so it really wasn't until I was a
sports reporter and so I majored in
journalism and then I found a class
called communications law that I just
fell in love with and from that minute
on I I knew I really wanted to think
about law school so I had a little time
in between undergrad and law when I
worked in sales and marketing and then
went to law school and have been so
happy I did there's so many things you
can do with a law degree and I really
enjoyed being in this profession and
what was it about that course in
communications law that got you hooked
you know we were asked to go to the law
librarian to find it on the campus and
to go in and read a famous case that was
about what's called libel which is when
you say something negative about a
public figure and could you be held
responsible for damages for that this
case is called New York Times versus
Sullivan and it's a famous one and we
were supposed to find it and read it and
I don't know really still what it was
but the minute I walked in that law
library and I started reading that
case I realized the laws made up of
stories you know everyone has a story
and these cases are the stories of times
when people may have had a difficult
time in their life or a challenging
issue and so I loved reading their story
and seeing how the law can help people
find a voice and find justice and then
and then how did that trajectory keep
going I actually felt similar things I
took a business law class while in
business school and I just was enamored
by it and I would say I was pre-law for
a moment and undergrad too so I was
definitely intrigued I read that book 1l
and I was really intrigued by it but the
so how did you go from law school to
where you are now what was uh you know
your path well let me just say I know
you keep pretty busy and we love what
you do but I can still talk to you about
law school you know my mom would might
like that law in high school so I really
enjoyed law school and I went to Indiana
University in Bloomington Indiana which
is where I'm from and I was so fortunate
to grow up in a town with a big State
University and I went there undergrad
and law school and after law school I
had the honor to clerk for a federal
judge and I learned a lot during that
year about watching the judges hear the
cases and the lawyers argue the cases
and I decided then that I really was
interested in being in the teaching side
of law there were things about legal
education that I liked but also things I
thought could be better and so I was
interested in being a law professor so I
started my career teaching law school
and was a professor teaching classes in
the business law area and also in the
law and in a quality area things like
race and law gender and law law and
sexuality and really enjoyed that after
a few years I was asked to serve as the
Dean of the law school where I was
teaching and I did that for about five
years and then I became the Dean of the
University of Washington School of Law
for eight years prior to coming to the
Law School Admission cow
and I was really intrigued by the Law
School Admission Council because I'd
always tried to work for educational
equity I believed so strongly in the
power of Education and so this is a
place where we can really help even the
playing field and help candidates
advance their education
ya know I definitely want to get into
that talking about that we're already
getting a lot of questions on YouTube
about the L SAT and kovat but before we
get to all of that I'd love your
thoughts on what are what are some of
the misconceptions about the law career
and stereotypes I guess what are
accurate sticker types and what are less
than accurate stereotypes well I think
one of the first things I would say
about that is that many times when
people think about what is a lawyer
they what comes to mind first is perhaps
a judge or a or lawyer who is in court
and that is part of what lawyers do but
lawyers are also I like to say you know
problem solvers in every field and
they're also in many ways referred to
sometimes as engineers for justice you
know the law is what gives our world the
possibility to thrive by enforcing
contracts and making sure people keep
their commitments and so really lawyers
work in every single field that there is
and you know I like to say that you know
if you think of a university or the
world law is kind of at the middle of
the hub every other thing has a
connection to it and so no matter what
your passion if its environment or civil
rights or music representing athletes or
arguing in court or building businesses
up and helping technology firms thrive
lawyers do all those things and more I
like I like that that phrase you
mentioned engineers for justice you know
I remember being surprised when I was an
undergraduate and I said maybe I'll be
going to law and I remember I you know I
start taking practice tests for the LS
18 I was like this is like a computer
science exam it has these deductive
reasoning problems these games and
obviously some reading comprehension and
logic why do you think that's
you know why do you think that's the
core of the LA's SAT that's like logic
this deductive reasoning etc I mean that
appeal to me is someone who had a very
strong math and engineering background
and you know most people don't see that
connection no it's true but math majors
do really well in law school and so do
music majors and so do many majors I
mean one of the fun things about law
schools it takes people from every major
and all of them you know can thrive so I
think really you know the L SAT is
designed to test the basic skills that
it takes to be successful in law school
and so it's not just a test it's a way
to build your skill that you're gonna
need when you get there and we've loved
having the free test prep through the
Khan Academy because we know that really
helps that skill building but so lawyers
are in many ways their creative
problem-solvers they have to learn to
think really creatively and to be able
to what I sometimes call look around
corners in other words you know what
comes next you know what's gonna happen
next how do you navigate uncertainty and
so the skills that the L SAT tests are
exactly the ones that one needs to be
able to do well as a lawyer and those
are things like reading really
critically and understanding what you're
reading thinking with reason and logic
being able to reason from evidence and
so those are the skills that will really
help you be of great use to your clients
because you'll be able to help them
solve their problems no and I really
like your point you know I think all too
often we either perceive ourselves or we
perceive other people as oh they're math
people they're science people they're
you know good
they're eloquent they're law people
that's kind of one of the stereotypes or
they're good writers whatever it might
be but the reality is you know I always
like to give the example of Abraham
Lincoln Abraham Lincoln obviously
practice law but he thought to make
himself a better lawyer he actually
learned all of the geometry proofs in
Euclid's elements and actually James
Garfield another
lawyer he actually has a novel proof of
Pythagorean theorem which he did while
sitting in the US House of
Representatives
so there's actually more cross
connections than I think most people
realize you know talking about our
relationship
with Khan Academy in the SAT and what
we'll talk more about that but you know
one question from YouTube mark Mari asks
how can we increase diversity in the
legal profession so I'd love your take
on that generally and then I'd also love
your take on how hopefully our
partnership might might play a role
there sure well diversity and equity are
so critical for law because our legal
profession really needs to mirror
society so that people trust it and so
that we can really see all the issues
that arise in a diverse world so the Law
School Admission Test and the Law School
Admission Council
our whole origination story is around
equity we were formed to help even the
playing field so that it didn't depend
just on who you knew or which school you
went to you could actually show the
skills you have and be able to get
attention for what you deserve which is
how you think about complex problems so
we really prioritize building the
pipeline to law school because as I
noted it's not always clear that some
people know how to go to law school some
people know that pathway some people
have good mentors others may not and so
we really try and build the pipeline and
open that window up so we can say you
know we need your voice in law too and
the more diverse those voices in law the
more law will get closer to that quest
for equal justice and that's what we all
strive for is to really merge law and
justice and so we know the diversity in
equity are critical parts of that and a
related question from YouTube
laya t asks how does the LSA al sac
support encourage first-generation and
low-income to is to apply for law school
and I'll just add to that you know you
said you're a first-generation college
student and a law student what would you
tell to students out there who are
thinking well it's kind of intriguing it
seems like a great profession
but it's you know after undergrad I got
after it's three more years
I'm probably going to have to incur debt
tuition doesn't seem cheap what would
you tell them if they're thinking about
it you know I think the most important
thing I would tell them is you know we
really need you
you know the coming out of the Cova
crisis and with all the struggles our
world has for equality and for justice
we really need voices like yours in the
legal profession so I want you to know
that the students who do go it is an
important investment but they're really
glad they did the careers are very
diverse and fulfilling and we do a lot
to help you on that in Roma journey we
have the free L SAT prep through the
Khan Academy also at LSA Sea Org we have
a lot of resources there to help the
candidates understand how to navigate
that pathway and then we work with our
member law schools and they all do a lot
of outreach and what we call pipeline
building to to help introduce students
to what it means to go to law school and
how to do that well and I think that one
of the things that are is just so
critical is that you know lawyers are a
really a wonderful group about mentoring
new new students and so you know we love
to share our you know actual thoughts
about what it means to be in law because
some people I think have two narrower
view of what it means to be a lawyer one
of the best examples I like to give of
that solves that often hear someone say
you know I have three kids and and one
of them they just argue with me all the
time
so that that I told him hey go to law
school well what I want to say is yes
that person may want to go to law school
and do well as a as an advocate but if
one of those children's a peacemaker we
need you to you know law is a
peacemaking profession as well it builds
a lot of common understanding and it
builds agreement negotiation it finds
ways to bring people together and move
forward collectively so whether
you're the one who argues or you're the
peacemaker there's room for you in law
no I'll just EE underline that we
actually have great internal counsel
here at Khan Academy your name is Julia
cowls and what I appreciate about her is
you know a lot of people have these
stereotypes that lawyers are you know
they're either always risk-averse or
they're trying to stick it to the other
person or they're trying to kind of
overwhelm everyone with really hard to
understand terminologies and so everyone
it feels a little bit lost but the
really great lawyers and I would
consider Julia to be one of them they
know how to you know you hat your
language has to be precise as a lawyer
so that both parties don't later say hey
I thought this no no no this is what we
agreed to so if the language is precise
then everyone knows what's going to
happen and you're less likely to get to
it into a disagreement later but then
also around the problem-solving around
can you make that language precise but
both parties don't think that they're
I'm kind of the losing end of the deal
and I think the best lawyers are
definitely those those problem solvers
and and we definitely have one here at
Khan Academy a question from Facebook
Lorraine a Laura asks would you consider
this a path for someone who's
middle-aged you know I would
my oldest student ever that graduated
was a doctor who graduated when he was
82 and he had decided wanted a degree
yeah oh middle aged it was awesome so
know it it's true that many people go to
law school right after college but I had
an almost almost six years in between
undergrad and law school and many people
have more years than that
and so it's a a great profession and
honestly when you've worked in some
other discipline many times you can then
use what you learned there and merger
with law and enhance your career that
way so law school really does welcome
people from very diverse backgrounds you
know any major any kind of you know many
ages and the other thing that's so
important to that I want to say is that
we also are working with our schools and
and we and our schools really are
serious about
when we say we welcome diverse students
we mean that widely viewpoint race and
ethnic diversity and also a key area
today is Disability Rights and that's
something that we've been working really
hard to open doors for opportunity two
more candidates who need accommodations
and testing or need accommodations in
pursuing their education and from
YouTube just going into this Kovach
crisis you know I'm curious generally
how how you're coping and how the whole
organization of the legal profession but
lady asks in specifically how is else
ACK administering the LSA tea and the
law school application during a Cova 19
yeah that's a great question and we had
to move very quickly to take the law
school admission test into format that
could be administered remotely so once
we realized that you know Colvin was
going to restrict travel and gatherings
for some time we couldn't give the test
in the field so our developers and
personnel worked day and night to
convert the L SAT to a system that can
be delivered and you can take it from
home with remote proctoring and that's
begun and that way we can make sure that
candidates continue their enrollment
journey so it's really important for us
to be able to do that and we're going to
do that as long as we can eat - while
this crisis is on the other thing we've
done is that we've been horrified by how
much this crisis has affected the world
in different ways based on again
inequality and so we've really been
redoubling our efforts on diversity and
equity we've been doing a lot of
webinars for candidates and also for our
schools to try and support everyone
through this time but that's a really
good question and what might have taken
two years to do we were able to really
do very quickly because we needed to we
had to help and I was really proud of
how LSA C responded and just following
up on that what our trends are are there
trends that you think are going to
happen because
of kovat 19 do you think applications
will go up they'll stay the same do you
think more people are thinking about
graduate school yeah I think that we're
gonna see strong demand for education I
mean obviously there's a lot of
uncertainty right now about what will
the fall look like and will it be what
people be back to campus or not will it
still be you know that everyone will
need to be learning remotely for a while
but many students are familiar with that
they're comfortable with it and so we're
seeing still very very strong demand for
legal education for this coming fall
and then the cycle where people start to
think about applying for next fall's
beginning as well and again it's still
very strong and I think that one of the
areas that I've always encouraged
students to think about is in timing you
know when do I go to law school is
always think about well what's my option
you know and if and right now the
economy is fairly disrupted you know in
many areas severely and so I think that
in a time when employments difficult
investing in education is a really great
solution and so I am I'm hoping and
anticipating that will still see a very
strong demand for legal ed and I'm glad
of that because we need it this crisis
has really shown so many areas that
Warriors are going to have to help
rebuild and you know the rule of law
needs to be respected and and strong and
the devastation that's been wrought by
this pandemic and continues to be as
something lawyers are going to have to
help with and help repair yeah and and
how do you see what our law schools
talking about right now in terms of
campus openings are they just following
whatever their the the universities
they're part of doing and what will is
it can you have an effective a legal
education if you know the first semester
the first year is done over over
videoconference of some kind you know
it's a it's a hard question because
legal education is a personalized form
of Education you know we don't do a lot
of just lecturing we really
engage with students and have a lot of
discussion we do a lot of hands-on you
know experiential education where you're
actually working with real clients and
you know solving real problems so it has
taken the creativity of the law schools
and they've responded in amazing ways
and had to respond as we all did so
quickly so you know I know this year I
was teaching law leadership at Villanova
and so you know one day I walked out of
my classroom not realizing I wouldn't be
able to walk back in and we quickly took
the course online
well that's being done you know all
across the world and I think that as the
fall come since the schools have had
even more time to prepare for that we'll
see any even stronger version of that if
it's not possible to bring the students
back to campus and right now I wish I
had an answer to that and everyone does
I think that everyone is preparing to
try and bring so you know some form of
Education back to campus but that's
something that the schools and
universities are working closely with
government officials on to to make sure
it's safe to do so because obviously the
safety of students is paramount so I
think that there's a lot of contingency
planning happening
some of you know maybe some in person
some online what if it has to stay
online for a certain amount of time but
I really feel a lot of confidence and
the enormous work the schools are doing
to prepare for that and they care about
the students and they'll put them first
and do well by them ya know that's the
super helpful yeah super unter I don't
know I don't think anyone really knows
how the snaps gonna play out but it's I
think everyone's doing pretty pretty
heroic jobs I mean a somewhat random
question from YouTube maja Kirk awaits
it says do you know Ruth Bader Ginsburg
I certainly know over and I've met her
and had the great pleasure of hearing
her speak a number of times and what a
wonderful figure for our world and I
admire her so very much not only her
work as a justice but the work she did
as a lawyer before the
as an advocate for for women in the law
and an advocate on gender equity more
broadly so she's uh she's one of the
real heroes of Justice I think for many
of us today ya know and just just as a
final question I'll just kind of group a
bunch of these questions you know some
questions like is law school hard or how
can I get through it you know I think
there's these you see in the movies
these people piling over these you know
seemingly dense books and they imagine
that's law school someone who's an
engineer prea B's talking about what I
make a good lawyer so you know just
maybe parting thoughts on anyone who
it's like wow law seems interesting but
it it seems hard whatever that might
mean what would you tell them what
advice would you give or just life
advice generally yeah so I guess in
terms of law school itself let me say
that you know when I started law school
I had no idea what to expect and I was
worried it would be so hard and and
something that you know could be out of
reach but I want to say that it is
really supportive today legal education
has changed a lot from the 1l book or
the Paperchase movie you might have seen
and the faculty members are so
supportive and there's great
infrastructure for student support and
academic support career support you name
it so I really know that today law
students can thrive and they get the
support that they need now that's not to
say that it isn't a rigorous form of
Education much of its value is that it
is and you will learn to think hard in
law school and you will learn to really
contribute to the world in so many ways
and to really help people you know I
think in its heart when you get a law
degree and you get your license you now
have a license to help people to make
change in the world to do good in the
world
and that's something that I really think
most of us really want to find an avenue
for we see the ways that our world as
beautiful it is in some ways is broken
and many others and we need to repair
that we need to work to make sure that
everyone has a chance to thrive in this
world
and that's really what law does it tries
to make sure that everyone has a chance
to flourish so I think if you have a
passion for wanting to make the world a
better place there's really no better
investment you can make then learning
the law and following your passion in
whatever direction that takes you Oh
Kelly you you've inspired me and so
thank thank you thank you so much for
for being part of this I think you've
just inspired a good chunk of new future
lawyers who can hopefully be the type
that can bring justice to the world for
all for us all well I think they can and
I want to say thanks to you you know you
and the Khan Academy and that you
inspire all of us and you know
educational equity is so critical and so
thanks for all you do to make that so
broadly available we really love our
partnership with you and look forward to
continuing likewise thank you so much
Kelly
my pleasure great to be with you so
thanks everyone for joining I thought
another very inspiring a livestream
guest especially if you're thinking
about the legal profession and I look
forward to seeing y'all tomorrow where
we're going to have the superintendent
of miami-dade on so that should be a
really interesting conversation I'll see
y'all tomorrow
you